bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal de la rédaction de tv fil 78 et
dans l'actualité de ce 21 janvier 2015
le mouvement de vous la france menée par
nicolas dupont aignan sera présent dans
les yvelines pour les prochaines
élections départementales
nous en parlerons avec thomas hugues
thomas garreau responsables dont les
yvelines de la communication de ce parti
1er janvier 2016 les intercommunalités
géante devrait voir le jour plus de huit
cent mille habitants pour saint quentin
en yvelines
les élus locaux qui s'opposent à ce
projet défendu par la région
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines vient de consacrer une
conférence à la liberté de la presse et
à la caricature une mise en perspective
des tragiques événements de ce début
d'année pour débuter cette information
deux jeunes hommes de 19 et 20 ans
originaire de trappes seraient partis
faire le djihad en fin de semaine
dernière c'est une femme qui aurait
signalé leur disparition hier soir selon
nos confrères du parisien il aurait
expliqué à leur famille se rendre à
l'étranger afin de valider une formation
au bafa l'un des deux hommes
travaillaient dans le domaine
périscolaire pour la commune de trappes
les services de la ville qui confirme
cette information sans faire pour
l'instant plus de commentaires l'enquète
se poursuit c'est donc aujourd'hui à
mercredi à l'issue du conseil des
ministres que manuel valls a annoncé une
série de mesures pour renforcer la lutte
contre le terrorisme 2680 emplois
supplémentaires seront créés au cours
des trois prochaines années au sujet de
la radicalisation en prison 60 aumônier
supplémentaires devraient être recrutés
le premier ministre a aussi annoncé la
création de cinq quartiers dédiés aux
regroupements de personnes détenues
radicaliser sur le modèle d'une
expérimentation qui se déroule
actuellement à la prison de fresnes
je vous propose d'écouter ce qu'en pense
cédric 13 il est le responsable syndical
ufap unsa justice dans les yvelines il
est également surveillants
pénitentiaires à bois d'arcy
il était l'invité du journal hier soir
le problème c'est incarcérés des détenus
des détenus par exemple ça se passe à
fresnes ils sont vingt ils sont une
vingtaine je crois à fresnes
ça se passe bien parce qu'ils sont
qu'une vingtaine
mais demain vous avez on parle des
centaines voire de milliers de jeunes
qui sont partis faire le djihad en syrie
ou en irak
on l'aimé où on l'aimé où on va pouvoir
voilà enfin créé des établissements mais
mais c'est pareil val relatifs au
système guantanamo - est-ce que c'est la
bonne solution
je sais pas ça veut dire qu'on l'aimé on
les enferme et puis on jette la clé
c'est peut-être pas la bonne idée c'est
peut-être se poser la question en amont
ceux qui sont déjà radicaliser on s'en
occupe mais il faut peut-être prévenir
ces mais ça c'est pas c'est pas le
boulot de la prison c'est le boulot du
gouvernement de prendre des bonnes
décisions et une bonne fois pour toutes
de prendre des décisions il faut
recruter des imams aussi bien il faut en
effet recruter des eaux me dise aumônier
musulman parce que eux sont importants
aujourd'hui alors ya des choses sur
lesquelles il faudra mettre des règles
mais il faut qu'il soit recruté parce
que on a besoin de plus de plus plus de
personnes qui sont qui sont tolérants et
la plupart des musulmans qui sont en
prison ne sont pas radicaux au contraire
même certains ont certainement dénoncer
mais dans les faits de masse de ce
qu'ils voulaient
stigmatiser la république en disant
c'est votre faute si on est en prison
ils sont pas ils se sont manifestés qui
vont s'écrire difficile d'avoir un
discours comme ça à manier à magny les
hameaux le maire a décidé de rendre
hommage à charlie hebdo en rebaptisant
le journal municipal le temps dans le
numéro manie mag deviendra pour le mois
de février charlie mag
bertrand ou lyon le maire qui souligne
dans son éditorial son attachement à la
laïcité garantie de la liberté de pensée
la liberté de la presse hier à
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une conférence
était proposée sur ce thème à tous les
étudiants
l'occasion surtout de proposer une
perspective historique au débat soulevé
par cette attaque contre la rédaction de
charlie hebdo le 7 janvier dernier
yolaine thorez y assister la liberté de
la presse et les caricatures dans la
france républicaine de thèmes actuels
qui ont rythmé la conférence proposée
hier à tous les étudiants de l'ub est ce
qu une rencontre à l'initiative de
l'institut d'études culturelles et
internationales et du centre d'histoire
culturelle des sociétés contemporaines
tous les infusions qui étaient ici on
semble partager l'émotion qu'on
partageait tous les français mais il
avait aussi besoin d'un peu de deux
prises à distance de perspective
historique celle monde recontextualiser
c'est l'humour old historians
recontextualiser mais aussi définir ses
dessins qui font l'actualité depuis
plusieurs semaines une caricature c'est
une charge par une caricature n'est pas
consensuelle aucune caricature est amené
à choquer et elle doit imposer
finalement son esprit de rire un rire
qui est parfois un peu effroyable mais
le rire quand même dans la société
la liberté de la caricature c'est une
certaine manière la preuve que la
liberté d'expression existe en france
parce que ya pas de liberté d'expression
s'il n'ya pas liberté de railleries de
moqueries et des changes finalement
autour du rire les étudiants repartent
avec et des connaissances en plus qui
leur permettent peut-être maintenant de
répondre à cette question peut-on
exprimé dans un journal as des idées
qu'ils n'enfreignent pas la loi et qui
permettait de se moquer de tout le monde
moi je suis c'est plutôt
plutôt de plutôt d'avis de laisser la
liberté d'expression et de laisser sa
caricature exister puisque les gens qui
sont choqués ne sont pas obligés de les
voir ou délire ce qu'on a vu beaucoup
sont sont cachés dans l'est certains
journaux des caricatures reste un bon
moyen d'exprimer nos volontés enfin
notre notre sentiment c'est pas le
sentiment de tout le monde forcément les
caricatures comme dit dans la conférence
sa place certains ça te plaît à d'autres
mais ça reste un moyen d'affirmer son
identité
l'actualité locale l'avenir des
intercommunalités pourrait se jouer
demain jeudi à l'occasion d'une réunion
de la crc rice et rci la commission
régionale de coopération intercommunale
à l'occasion de cette réunion les élus
yvelinois compte bien faire voter un
amendement pour proposer une toute
nouvelle carte
les détails avec quatre nuls attend
demain la casse qui n'aura plus le même
visage au 1er janvier 2016 les
intercommunalités autour du grand paris
devront compter plus de deux cent mille
habitants
le préfet de région a présenté cet été
son projet d'une interco à huit cent
mille habitants de versailles grand parc
à l'essonne en passant par saint quentin
en yvelines
une vraie levée de boucliers des élus
contre ce projet un amendement a
d'ailleurs été déposée par le président
du conseil général pierre bédier signé
du président de la caf qui michel
laugier et du président de versailles
grand parc françois de mazières
un amendement qui propose une nouvelle
réorganisation territoriale
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise
s'agrandirait en se fusionner avec la
communauté de l'ouest parisien qui
comprend les villes de plaisir les
clayes sous bois et villepreux et les
communes de maurepas et de coignières
versailles grand parc accueille de son
côté la ville de vélizy un premier pas
ce serait deux intercommunalités
distincts de plus de deux cent mille
habitants et qui reste raids dans les
frontières départementales des îles la
logique un jour
sera de mon point de vue que versailles
et saint quentin fasse la même
intercommunalité parce que ces mêmes
territoires c'est même bassin
d'activités de vie etc
ça j'y crois profondément mais
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup trop tôt de
mon point de vue c'est pas avant dix
quinze ou vingt ans qu'on pourra
imaginer d'avoir un grand sens mais
c'est de mon point de vue l'avenir est
là l'amendement doit être voté demain on
s'est essayé pour qu'ils soient adoptés
il faut que deux tiers des membres le
cautionne la cercil de france comprend
86 membres dont 17 illinois parmi ceux
ci le président du conseil général le
président de l'acca ski ou encore le
maire de magny les hameaux bertrand au
lion politique c'est l'heure de
l'entretien de ce journal les je reçois
aujourd'hui thomas garreau bonsoir
bonsoir revenu en plateau vous êtes le
délégué départemental à la communication
de debout la france la formation
politique de nicolas dupont aignan un
parti qui a changé de nom la fin de
l'année dernière debout la république
qui devient donc debout la france fin
décembre pourquoi ce changement ait lieu
ce changement ait lieu parce que on est
dans une optique de rassemblement et on
estime que c'est pas forcément la
république est en danger actuellement
mais c'est plutôt le pays c'est la
france qui dans le maelström européen
est noyé et debout la france nous
paraissait un nom plus rassembleur il
est plus rassembleur fédérateur autour
de l'identité française l'identité
française dans ce qu'elle a de plus beau
c'est à dire son histoire sa culture ne
voyait pas le terme identité comme
identitaire bien ce nom et où justement
aussi tu la formation politique
aujourd'hui entre l'ump et le front
national
droite classique + plus dur comment vous
définiriez c'est difficile parce que
actuellement les cartes sont tellement
brouiller le clivage gauche-droite a
plus vraiment de sens de nos jours quand
le parti socialiste fait le programme
que l'ump aurait souhaité faire quand le
front national nous propose le programme
économique du parti communiste des
années 60
le clivage gauche-droite a plus vraiment
de sens donc le parti debout la france
c'est un parti républicain qui est veut
défendre un patriotisme serein et qui
est dans une idée économiquement on est
sur une idée de l'état stratège mais pas
de rapprochement en tout cas avec l'ump
ou même avec le front national on
l'entend de la dupont aignan a suspendu
une des candidates acquis sur lui lui
son café c'était pendant les hymnes et
s'est rapproché du fromage on est sûr
d'une optique ni système ni extrêmes
c'est-à-dire que on pourra pas s'en
sortir avec des gens qui ont mis la
france dans cet état pendant les trente
dernières années
mais on n'est pas non plus obligé de
s'enfermer dans ce choix de mort qui est
de devoir choisir systématiquement entre
le front national où le ps et l'ump
espèce de triangle des bermudes
politique
on a le droit à d'autres choix les
français ont le droit à d'autres choix
et en proposant cette voie à nicolas
dupont aignan debout la france propose
le rassemblement soit juste vous faire
réagir à l'actualité du jour après les
attentats de ce début d'année
nicolas dupont aignan avaient appelé à
suspendre les accords de schengen à
rétablir les contrôles fixes aux
frontières à recourir à l'état d'urgence
ce matin il ya eu des annonces faites
par le premier ministre on a parlé au
début du journal
est ce que ces deux matinées manière à
vous rassurer ce qui a été annoncé ce
matin plus de moyens des aumôniers dans
les prisons des justes de moyens c'est
forcément bien le fait qu'ils aient
moins de suppressions de postes de
policiers que prévu c'est une chose mais
il ya toujours des suppressions de
postes malheureusement et nicolas dupont
aignan a demandé à ce qu'on met l'état
d'urgence en place pour tout simplement
donner plus de moyens à la police qu'on
puisse faire quelque chose qui est utile
c'est-à-dire désarmer les cités pouvoir
faire des perquisitions
il faut aller plus loin encore when he
sees il faut aller plus loin les petites
mesurettes c'est plus possible il faut
qu'on aille plus loin il faut qu'on
puisse faire en sorte que les armes de
guerre ne circulent plus sur le
territoire on avait on avait accusé
nicolas dupont aignan de faire du
spectacle pendant les européennes quand
il a fait passer une kalachnikov par la
frontière pour montrer la porosité des
frontières
aujourd'hui on voit que c'était pas du
spectacle on va parler départemental
c'est pour ça que vous êtes venu nous
voir aujourd'hui on va parler de vous
également parce que vous venez
de ce poste de chargé de communication
dans les yvelines pourquoi votre soutien
vous avez 28 ans pourquoi vous engager
aux côtés de la formation de nicolas
dupont aignan parce que je suis à un âge
où je me dis que je prépare mon avenir
et je prépare l'avenir de mes enfants et
par conséquent c'est important de
s'engager en politique
ici on laisse faire les autres on n'a
pas de se plaindre
donc il faut s'engager et puis auprès du
point bien parce que je suis d'accord
avec toutes ces idées au niveau tant
économiques souveraineté nationale etc
chaque soir dans ce journal vous avez la
parole à travers notre micro-trottoir
notre question du jour qui est dédié
forcément à cette séquence du journal
nous sommes allés vous demandez quelle
image vous aviez de nicolas dupont
aignan vos réponses je peux répondre
assez médiatique peut-être nicolas
dupont aignan je ne connais pas très
bien plutôt de droite je ne pense pas
grand chose honnêtement je pense qu'il
est trop il est trop isolé
il me semble qu'il va partir un peu au
passé aussi j'ai déjà entendu le nom oui
mais
je le situe pas tu pourrais nous on sait
ce qui c'est le maire de le maire d'auch
celui là je sais pas moi ce qu'on n'est
pas un peu comme tous les politiques en
ce moment ce jeu pages les couteaux un
cdd dans 77 et très propre sur lui très
bien je veux dire à beaucoup de ski dit
voilà je suis très très très content de
monsieur dupont-aignan mais je et là
c'est un combat pas tellement pas
tellement sûr de gagner un peu de
travail encore pour la notoriété c'est
le gros souci c'est l'affichage
médiatique et le fait de se faire
connaître parce que je vous assure que
plus les gens apprendront à le connaître
plus il a mon ses idées ils seront
d'accord avec lui le problème c'est que
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
2012 il a été très peu exposés et alors
on essaye ça progresse
on progresse à chaque élection fait des
meilleurs scores les gens commencent à
connaître mais effectivement il ya un
gros boulot et c'est ce que nos
militants vont faire pendant ces
élections et les prochaines aller sur le
terrain parler aux gens et et faire
connaître ces élections ce sont celles
des départementales les prochaines se
serait ensuite les régionales on va déjà
se concentrer son se concentrer sur
l'échéance de 2 mars vous serez candidat
d'ailleurs tout ça sera officialisée
demain à versailles en présence de
nicolas dupont aignan et quelle
stratégie pour votre formation politique
est ce qu'il y aura des candidats
partout au départemental dans les
yvelines dans tous les cantons alors on
sera présent dans plus de la moitié des
cantons
c'est difficile d'être présent partout
notamment pour un parti qui est jeune
comme debout la france
faut dire aussi que la réforme qui a été
fait pour ces élections est fait pour ça
les fait pour faire en sorte que les que
les gros partis qu'ils puissent
présenter partout mais on va essayer de
se présenter dans un maximum de cantons
avec des gens compétents et motivés
un handicap principal c'est le la
formation des binômes c'est pour ça
cette réforme qui maintenant met en
place des binômes qui vont devoir siéger
il y aura deux candidats sur sur chacun
des cantons même quatre avec les
supplices sahel redécoupage des cantons
aussi alors le fait de faire des binômes
en soit c'est pas très compliqué
d'appliquer la parité de toute façon
nous c'est pas un problème vraiment
qu'on a deux bouts la france aux
législatives de 2012 ont été le seul
parti qui avait plus de femmes que
d'hommes sur nos listes on a d'ailleurs
été condamné à cause de ça mais sinon
annoncé le fait de pouvoir présenter
partout dans tous les cantons
c'est assez difficile mais on va essayer
d'être présente dans le maximum vous
vous serez présent candidat sur le
canton de vaud
oui je serai candidat ici vous êtes
installé à montigny le bretonneux canton
difficile détenus pour l'instant par la
gauche on parle d'une éventuelle
candidature du président de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin pour représenter l'ump lui dei
quelles sont vos ambitions sur ce
scrutin
les ambitions c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible bien sûr l'ambition minimum
c'est de passer la barre des 5% pour se
faire rembourser la campagne mais on
vise forcément plus puis on va
travailler pour essayer on va les
rencontrer les gens sur les marchés dans
les niveaux dans les cars dans les
centres commerciaux on va aller parler
aux gens qui ont essayé de ramener le
plus de voix possible
le choix des cantons puisque vous serez
pas présents partout ma sfere comment
par rapport aux gens qui sont motivés
pour y aller et aux dynamiques locales
si on a des personnes qui sont motivés
dans les cantons qui se présentent dans
leur canton pitt dans certains cantons
ne peut pas il ya des secteurs
particuliers déjà qu'ils sont ciblés sur
lesquels vous pouvez nous dire déjà ce
soir même si les noms ne sont pas encore
connues qu'il y aura une candidature on
sera présent systématiquement au moins
dans un canton dans chaque
circonscription législative donc on au
niveau du maillage territorial sur les
yvelines on sera présents partout donc
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines autres bien sûr il y aussi une
hausse serait forcément représentait
alors on parlait de cette présence il
faut des axes de campagne
également vous dites qu'il faut affirmer
que les yvelinoises les yvelinois ne
sont pas condamnés à être dirigées par
des élus condamnés ou corrompus ces
salles axes de campagne à l'est de caen
même si c'est ça c'est quelque chose qui
est qui est vrai dans les yvelines qui
est vrai aussi au niveau national c'est
le fait qu'on peut plus continuer avec
des élus qui sont corrompus qui sont
condamnés il faut moraliser la vie
politique et la vie publique
d'ailleurs en ce sens nicolas dupont
aignan vient de déposer trois projets de
loi avec trois autres députés à
l'assemblée nationale qui vise à
moraliser la vie publique et qui propose
notamment à ce que les élus qui sont
condamnés pour les abus de biens sociaux
détournement d'argent public etc ne
puisse plus être éligible du tout stop
au gaspillage à la distribution opaque
des subventions là aussi vous pensez
aujourd'hui pour ceux ciblés sur le
département des yvelines que les
priorités ne sont pas mises là où elle
devrait non effectivement il faut savoir
que dans les yvelines sur la période de
2006 à 2013
il ya plus de 8 millions d'euros qui ont
été données pour des subventions à
l'international on pense pas forcément
noah debout la france que ce soit le
rôle du département de faire ça alors
subventionner des associations locales
c'est bien d'ailleurs le département le
fait en 2014 à hauteur de 77 mille euros
mais c'est bien peu au mas des petites
associations qui auraient besoin de plus
ici quand on sait qu'un élu dans les
yvelines ça coûte 50 mille euros par an
on se dit que 77 mille euros aux
associations locales s'est pas beaucoup
l'échelon départemental est
véritablement important nécessaire il a
été remis en cause on évoquait la
disparition il ya quelques mois encore
des conseils généraux là maintenant il
ya des élections va falloir mobiliser
les électeurs leur expliquer qu'il faut
encore aller voter malgré ces doutes qui
planent au dessus de l'institution que
représente l'institution départementale
on parlait aussi tout à l'heure plutôt
dans le journal de des intercommunalités
qui sont appelés à à grossir ça fait
beaucoup de strates 1 pour sa vue baisse
et le sujet sempiternelle qui ressort
tout le temps du fameux millefeuille
administratif français
noah debout la france on a une
conception très simple du millefeuille
administratif si on était au pouvoir et
qu'on devait faire une réforme
territoriale on a trois niveaux qui pour
nous sont importants la ville la commune
le département et l'état
pour nous ces grosses régions là un
gouverneur qui vont devenir des
potentats locaux c'est pas du tout la
direction vers laquelle il faut aller et
on est en total désaccord avec le
gouvernement et le parti socialiste qui
propose de supprimer les départements
pour nous le département c'est un
échelon à taille humaine c'est un âge un
échelon qui s'occupe de donner les aides
sociales qui s'occupe de nos personnes
âgées en donnant la pas qui s'occupe de
recruter les auxiliaires de vie scolaire
c'est un échelon à taille humaine et
pour nous c'est vraiment au coeur de
l'état il faut plutôt supprimer tout ce
qui est région et ne pas aller vers des
grosses intercommunalités
effectivement pour nous les grosses
intercommunalités peuvent avoir un sens
dans certains cas ça doit être traité au
cas par cas mais il faut pas chercher
l'emmène mutualisé aussi des moyens là
effectivement il ya des pour les
transports effectivement c'est très
important
les régions de la même façon
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir des grosses
régions peut-être que nos élus
départementaux peuvent se réunir et
discuter des questions importantes comme
les universités etc mais non pour nous
le département c'est vraiment au coeur
de l'état comment va se dérouler cette
campagne aussi bien votre campagne sur
montigny lui en cours que la campagne
globalement vous allez être très présent
vous voulez impulser la dynamique dès à
présent où ce sera une campagne courte
ce sera une campagne courte et forcément
mais on va travailler en amont quand
même là on a commencé une campagne
nationale avec des affiches national
avec le fameux hashtag engagez-vous sur
nos affiches avec à la marianne qui vont
d'ailleurs commencer à être visible on a
commencé à coller un peu partout dans
les yvelines ça va être de plus en plus
visible on va également tracter avec des
tracteurs plus nationaux et puis quand
la campagne sera lancée quand on aura
bien boucler toutes nos listes qui
devraient arriver dans pas très
longtemps on aura cette fois ci une
nouvelle campagne d'affichage avec des
nouvelles affiches et des nouveaux
tracts pour nos différents candidats les
candidats en tout cas qui ne
commenceront à être dévoilé dès demain à
versailles à l'hôtel de ville en
présence à la salle montgolfier à
versailles demain oui merci d'être venus
en photo thomas garreau délivre son
talent à la communication de debout la
france je rappelle que vous êtes d'ores
et déjà vous candidat sur montigny
guyancourt vous résidez d'ailleurs sur
montigny le bretonneux les autres noms
des candidats à partir de demain on vous
les annoncera dans ce journal bien
évidemment la suite à présent de cette
édition du 21 janvier avec les flocons
de neige qui était attendu dans le
département pour ce mercredi qui ne sont
finalement pas tomber les services de
voirie était pourtant mobilisé le plan
hivernal est lancée depuis le 15
novembre il va se poursuivre jusqu'au 15
mars de quoi s'agit-il plus précisément
les explications pas encore de neige
mais les saleuses sont prêtes le plan
hivernal est déclenché depuis le 15
novembre
une procédure qui s'appuie sur une
veille météo des patrouilles de terrain
pour constater l'état des chaussées et
des patrouilles de vérification des
traitements ici à la casse qui on se
doit de veiller sur 150 km de voies
intercommunal pour répondre aux besoins
du service hivernal nous avons dit
saleuses 9 qui interviennent plus une
qui en cas de secours à la fois un
service de jour
donc ces trois personnes qui sont
mobilisées
à la cs saint quentin en yvelines plus
bien sûr entreprises laignel donc qu'ils
ont justement ce boulot de chauffeur
auxquels ils font appel des demandes
d'intervention 20 chauffeurs sont
d'astreinte et cinq bénévoles agents de
l'agglomération se relaie le soir le
week-end et les jours fériés avec des
impératifs en cas de neige dégager les
axes de circulation le matin et le soir
aux heures de pointe
cinq lignes de bus dites prioritaires
doivent également être rendue circulable
le plus rapidement possible tout cela a
un coût le coup bien sûr ils varient
d'une saison à l'autre puisque il est
fonction du nombre de sorties mais on
est sur une base d'astreinte de à peu
près six cent mille euros à sa faut
ajouter les sorties et faut compter un
peu près quinze mille euros la sortie en
préventif depuis le 15 novembre début de
la campagne d'hiver les équipes ont salé
à quatre reprises en prévention la
dernière fois en début de semaine le sel
utilisé est celui de l'année dernière
qu'il n'avait pas été consommés en
raison d'une météo clémente pour suivre
l'évolution de la météo et des
différentes procédures
les particuliers peuvent s'inscrire via
un système d'alertés sms et depuis deux
ans des bacs à sable sont installés sur
les routes en pente le sable qui
pourrait être bien utile aux
automobilistes en cas de verglas
objectif éviter la déroute de l'hiver
2012 un portrait pour refermer ce
journal l'écrivaine yvelinoise et me
rend ce bel this publie son 16e titre
une trilogie appelé témoignage de
village trois ouvrages durant lesquelles
on suit l'évolution de ce département
des petits villages à la ville nouvelle
l'agglomération l'auteur raconte son
enfance ses années lycée ou encore son
installation au technocentre renault à
guyancourt yvelines thorez et william r
imerys betis habite jouars-pontchartrain
depuis 34 ans écrivain autoédité elle
vient de publier une trilogie littéraire
intitulé témoignage de village trois
ouvrages dont le premier retrace ses
souvenirs d'enfance ces moments à
l'école primaire et sa vie partagée
entre deux villages qui lui sont chers
j'ai écrit pour qu'on se souvienne que
il y avait
voilà il y avait des des habitants dans
ces villages et que en fait ma famille
en particulier a contribué aux liens
entre ces deux villages puisque mais mes
parents
l'un était d'elancourt et l'autre de
derghal encouragé par ses proches et
mehr ans raconte dans son deuxième
ouvrage ses années lycée elle y fait son
entrée à l'âge de 10 ans est la seule
solution à l'époque c'est le lycée
mansart de saint-cyr-l'ecole encarté
dans le rabat de la couverture l'auteur
a créé ce petit livret sur la mode des
années 70 dans tous les domaines
notamment celui des vêtements avec les
pantalons pattes d'éléphant minijupe ou
encore les premiers jeans
ça c'était pour ma première boum c'était
dans des baumes
vient ensuite le dernier livre de la
trilogie
elle y raconte notamment la naissance du
technocentre renault à guyancourt
ce sont les années 90 les salariés
doivent quitter les locaux de reuil
malmaison et de boulogne-billancourt
il ya eu un grand grand mouvement social
parmi les ingénieurs et techniciens de
renault
pour diverses raisons mais il y avait
une raison qui était quand même
importante c'est l angoisse de ces
transferts un témoignage pour ne pas
oublier garder la mémoire et transmettre
aux jeunes voilà comment une errance
betis décrit cette trilogie une
trentaine d'exemplaires sont élite et à
se procurer directement auprès d'elle le
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines a décidé de les acquérir pour
son fonds documentaire
de quoi donner de belles perspectives à
cet auteur qui ne manque pas de projets
futurs fin de ce journal je vous
retrouve demain jeudi pour un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité locale
tout de suite sur télé fil 78
le nouveau numéro deux kiosques le
magazine de la culture présentée par
catherine château bonne soirée